eppingen in bad neuenahr-ahrweiler im
august fünf wochen nach der
flutkatastrophe
hier wohnten nadine und seinen templeton
mit ihren drei monate alten sohn terence
sie zeigen uns ihr haus im neubaugebiet
oder vielmehr das was noch davon übrig
ist
das kinderzimmer
ja das ist hier unsere dachluke
nachts dann
raus mussten wir durch geklettert die
ganze nacht saß die kleinfamilie auf dem
dach ihres neubaus und banken um ihr
leben die 400 meter von ihrem haus
entfernt war zu einem reißenden strom
geworden erst am nächsten morgen wurden
sie mit einem boot von der feuerwehr
gerettet jetzt stehen sie vor den
trümmern ihrer existenz
schon schlimm die gearbeitet das alles
selbst aufgebaut und
alles weg
als gut
so viele immer wohnt halt
ne na.de will steht noch rum liegt oder
meinen jimmy an gewürzt eine ecke nicht
obwohl die beiden regelmäßig hierher
kommen ist es für sie immer noch
schmerzhaft jedes mal kommen die
erinnerungen an die flut nacht wieder
hoch hätte jemand damit gerechnet dass
ist ja so ein hochwasser geben
dadurch laufen das ist knöchelhoch das
wasser hat oder vielleicht kniehoch aber
es ist eine serie schon da eigentlich
ich bin fest auf aussagen gekommen die
wasser hin es ist ein ort wurde sicher
deine familie gründen kannst und dann
wenn wir das gewusst hätten wir das
keine option gewesen
der schaden allein für das gebäude liegt
bei rund 300.000 euro immerhin hat das
paar eine versicherung die die kosten
für den wiederaufbau übernehmen wird
aber nur an dieser stelle ihr seid ihr
jetzt fest entschlossen hier wieder
aufzubauen
hättet ihr überhaupt eine andere
möglichkeit im prinzip müssen wir
finanzieren das haus wir müssen hier
aufbauen wir könnten natürlich dann
sagen wir verkaufen ist wer kauft hier
in der gegend ein haus ist die nächste
frage und dann findet es mal was anderes
neubaugebiet oder im grundstück mit kind
ist jetzt alles nicht so einfach
erst vor sechs jahren war das gebiet zur
bebauung freigegeben worden insgesamt 40
häuser standen hier in fast allen lebten
junge familien mit kindern sie alle
bauten hier in dem glauben sicher zu
sein mit einem hochwasser dieses
ausmaßes rechnete hier kaum einer jetzt
sind fast alle häuser unbewohnbar ein
haus ist komplett weggeschwemmt zwei
menschen starben in den fluten die
strömung hatte alles mitgerissen was
sich ihr in den weg gestellt hat
hätten die familien in heppingen in bad
neuenahr wissen können welches risiko
für ihre grundstücke besteht
hochwassergefahren werden von den
jeweiligen landesregierungen in karten
ausgewiesen die frei im internet
zugänglich sind wir schauen uns die
hochwasser karten für bad neuenahr an
die vor der katastrophe im sommer galten
hier ist eingezeichnet welche
wasserstände bei hochwasser erwartet
werden hochwasser war laut karte für das
neubaugebiet kaum wahrscheinlich selbst
bei einem extremen hochwasser wie im
sommer wurde von einer wassertiefe von
höchstens einem meter ausgegangen in der
realität waren es bei dieser flut jedoch
fast drei meter
wieso haben die behörden das
hochwasserrisiko für das neubaugebiet
derart unterschätzt wir fragen nach bei
der stadt bad neuenahr die das baugebiet
ausgewiesen hat für ein interview steht
man uns nicht zur verfügung sondern
verweist uns an die für die hochwasser
karten zuständige behörde des landes
diese teilt uns schriftlich mit die
karten basieren auf den hochwasser
statistiken der pegel dort wo keine
langen messreihen vorhanden sind wird
der wert für ein sehr seltenes
hochwasser extrapoliert also abgeschätzt
extrapolation ist immer mit einer
unschärfe verbunden
paulo reggiani hat das europäische
hochwasser frühwarn system mit
entwickelt und forscht aktuell an der
universität siegen zu wasser
wirtschaftlichen risiken und klimafolgen
schon 2016 habe es eine kritische
hochwasserlage gegeben
hätte man so eine flutkatastrophe wie
die die jetzt im juli geschehen ist
hätte man sowas vorhersehen können ich
würde sagen es war ein déjà vu ja also
es ist ja nichts neues dass in diesem
jahr einzugsgebiet
zwar selten aber extrem hochwasser
aufdreht wir haben sehr gute
überlieferungen aus 19 10 das ist
vergleichbar mit dem was ich jetzt im
juli 2021 zugetragen hat 20 16 sind wir
ganz in die nähe gekommen
aber wie wahrscheinlich es ist dass
sowas wiedereintritt
ja so aus der aufarbeitung der
statistisch also da da da dam es rein
die wir haben ist es eigentlich gar
nicht mal so unwahrscheinlich dass es
wieder aufgeregt wie sehen sie das denn
ist ein wiederaufbau
wirklich sinnvoll oder überhaupt sicher
ja ich persönlich würde es nicht tun
aber
natürlich wenn man wieder aufbaut muss
man das mit einer ganz anderen
herangehensweise machen mit einem ganz
anderen bewusstsein nämlich dass man
sich in einer zone von beachtlichen
hochwasserrisiko befindet doch genau
diese risiko lage war fielen im aartal
nicht bewusst
ende august sind wir noch einmal im
eppinger neubaugebiet im aartal wir sind
unterwegs mit baugutachter ralf steins
er hat heute einen termin mit jürgen und
irina [ __ ] zu diesem zeitpunkt wissen
die beiden noch nicht wie es weitergeht
prüfstein schätzt heute ein wie groß der
schaden an ihrem haus ist und ob ein
wiederaufbau überhaupt möglich ist
1 hallo
ich schaue mal in ruhe die substanz von
außen an die
schäden und dann gehen wir nach innen
und gucken uns einfach mal ihre
situation angenommen
was erhofft ihr euch heute hier fangen
im gutachten wir wollen schon wissen ob
sich tatsächlich das lohnt hier nochmal
eine sanierung durchzuführen wir wissen
dass die sanierung kosten technik an nah
am neubau liegen denn das absolut nicht
sinnvoll ist ja wenn die kosten und die
aufwände vor allem die zeitliche aufwand
so groß sind müssen wir quasi abreißen
neu bauen
jürgen und irina [ __ ] lebten noch nicht
lange in heppingen ein eigenes haus mit
garten für sich und ihre zwei kinder das
war für sie die erfüllung eines lange
gehegten traums jetzt stehen sie vor dem
nichts ihr haus war bis ins obergeschoss
überflutet über 14 stunden saßen sie
unterm dach und warteten auf rettung
heute stehen sie vor der frage sanieren
oder abreißen
dieser schaumstoff oder styropor der
saugt das wasser auf ihr merkt man ja
auch noch jetzt deutlich also da brauche
ich auch nicht mit dem porsche messgerät
dran gehen also ist deutlich spürbar
die ganze fassade bis mindestens erhöhe
des wassers muss runter auf jeden fall
rund 300.000 euro hatte allein das haus
gekostet ein wirtschaftlicher
totalschaden für das paar die beiden
haben keine elementarschadenversicherung
die für hochwasser schäden aufkommt sie
hoffen beim wiederaufbau auf finanzielle
hilfe vom bund um die beantragen zu
können brauchen sie das gutachten
können sie da schon was sagen mir ihr
erster eindruck so ist ja gut diese nass
geworden ganz klar aber
die waren nicht lange genug im wasser um
schimmel anzusetzen
die holzträger können also bleiben die
elektro verdrahtung nicht fahren
ralf steins hat sich jetzt ein bild
gemacht
lohnt sich ein wiederaufbau
sind schon elementare schäden da aber es
ist nicht undenkbar und von innen kann
wieder neu aufgebaut werden die haben im
prinzip jetzt einen rohbauzustand
es gibt ja schon mal ganz gut dass man
einiges hier noch retten kann und dass
sie vor den grundsätzlich möglich ist
weil wir entschlossen hier wieder
aufzubauen hier wieder zu leben wir
müssen einfach versuchen wir haben keine
alternative wo wir hingehen können es
gibt kaum wohnraum hin der gegend ich
glaube dass das nicht realistisch ist
woanders hinzugehen
die angst vor hochwasser bleibt aber die
moas haben kaum eine alternative
wohnraum ist überall knapp aber macht
ein wiederaufbau in einem gebiet das so
stark von den wassermassen betroffen war
überhaupt sinn bei gutachter ralf stein
scannt die gesamte region um die a sehr
gut und auch die probleme in der
bebauung wie denen sie das denn mit dem
wiederaufbau sollte man jetzt einfach
alles wieder so aufbauen wie bisher oder
muss man jetzt vielleicht auch gucken
dass man irgendwie etwas anders macht
als vorher ja durchaus da müssen andere
gedanken einfließen wenn man
baugrundstücke ausweist die folgen
einfach noch tiefer den rohbau ich wie
baue ich da sollte man auch wirklich
eigentlich jedes projekt hinterfragen
sechs wochen später hat das land
entschieden wo im aartal wieder
aufgebaut werden darf und neue
hochwasserrisiko karten erstellt nur 34
häuser im aartal dürfen nicht wieder
aufgebaut werden das henninger
neubaugebiet gilt nun offiziell als
überschwemmungsgebiet optimus und die
templeton es hier tatsächlich wieder
aufbauen dürfen
wieder aufbauen oder mehr fläche für den
hochwasserschutz genau um dieses thema
ging es auch in sachsen nach dem
elbehochwasser 2002 ein ereignis das als
jahrhundertkatastrophe galt
ich glaube der wird sich einprägen das
wird man nie wieder vergisst
roth rau süd in sachsen 2002 damals
stand hier ein neubaugebiet es wurde vom
elbe hochwasser komplett überspült
heute ist hier wieder ackerland drei
monate nach dem hochwasser beschloss die
damalige landesregierung den ort
komplett abzureißen alle 443 bewohner
wurden in benachbarte ortschaften
umgesiedelt und finanziell entschädigt
das problem nur viele bewohner hatten da
schon mit dem wiederaufbau ihrer häuser
begonnen und mussten wieder abreißen wir
treffen hier ekkehard beelitz von der
landestalsperrenverwaltung sachsen
damals betriebsleiter für das obere
elbtal wo stehen wir genau wo sind wir
gerade wir stehen hier auf dem deich da
die elbe hier der deich das ist ein
hochwasserabfluss gebiet das gesamte tal
und speziell hier dadurch der ist ja
ganz bewusst von unseren vorfahren nicht
so hoch wie möglich gebaut wurden
sondern so dass sich hier im gesamten
gebiet
ausbreiten und hier ablesen kann
das neubaugebiet hätte hier niemals
gebaut werden dürfen nur elf jahre nach
der flut im osten gab es ein erneutes
elbehochwasser widerstand die fläche
komplett unter wasser das wohngebiet
wäre wieder abgesoffen was hat man in
sachsen aus den hochwasserkatastrophen
gelernt wie bei vielen anderen dingen im
leben ist ja immer die frage muss man
alles machen was man theoretisch darf
denn die tatsache dass man vielleicht
unter bestimmten bedingungen hinter
einem teich in der nähe eines flusses
bauen dürfte heisst da nicht das dicke
vorweg ist in riederau süd konnten
konsequenzen gezogen werden die menschen
wurden umgesiedelt die häuser abgerissen
wir sind noch einmal in heppingen im
aartal inzwischen sind mehr als zwei
monate seit der flutkatastrophe
vergangen nadine und seinen templeton
wohnen noch immer in einem bürogebäude
vermittelt von freunden die kleinfamilie
freundet sich immer mehr mit dem
gedanken an wieder in ihrem alten
zuhause zu leben inzwischen ist klar
dass sie wieder aufbauen dürfen obwohl
die beiden noch nicht wissen wie das
gebiet künftig vor hochwasser geschützt
werden soll und welche auflagen dann für
sie gelten sind sie entschlossen ihr
haus wieder instand zu setzen
haben hier
arbeite ich im ort hier habe ich meine
freunde nachbarn und wir wollen dich
immer wieder zurück wenn ihr jetzt
wieder aufbaut werdet ihr da
irgendwelche maßnahmen ergreifen werdet
ihr irgendwie anders wieder aufbauen
also mit blick auf hochwasserschutz
ja es war es gibt so hochwasserschutz
türen wir versuchen wir an zu schaffen
das ist natürlich alles eine preisliche
sache das hilft aber auch nur bei
hochwasser nicht bei einer flut also wir
reden jetzt bei hochwasser meter oder
fünf zentimeter genau und wir machen
eine leiter dahin wir machen an und
scheiben einzuschlagen so ein
ding dahin und einen kleinen rucksack
mit irgendwas nicht
dass man weiß wenn sie nicht packe mir
einfach diesen rucksack packt die leiter
und ich kann doch wohl nur noch groß zu
überlegen
die angst vor einer neuen flut sie
bleibt auch eine straße weiter gehen sie
die dinge pragmatisch an irina und
jürgen [ __ ] rollen weiter auf auch sie
haben sich entschieden ihr haus wieder
aufzubauen
wie geht es euch wie blickt er jetzt in
die zukunft
optimistisch also wir wissen wir werden
irgendetwas bekommen vom land wir gehen
davon aus dass wir das haus davon
sanieren können dass wir wieder hier
leben können und dann geht es uns
eigentlich ganz gut weil wir wissen dass
es noch ein langer weg sein wird aber
optimistischer
inzwischen hat der bund einen aufbau vom
für die flutopfer beschlossen irena und
jürgen [ __ ] werden wahrscheinlich 80
prozent der schäden erstattet bekommen
wie man aber die bewohner in heppingen
künftig besser vor hochwasser schützen
möchte dazu traf der landkreis ahrweiler
noch keine aussage wir werden es in
zukunft häufiger mit starkregen und
anderen wetterextremen zu tun haben
weiter bauen wie bisher und immer mehr
fläche zubetonieren macht die gefahr
noch größer wir müssen anders bauen mit
der natur nicht gegen sie sonst können
aus kleinen rinnsalen wieder tödliche
fluten werden
[Musik]